in 2007 kunas told parade that the
thought of reprising her role as Jackie
from that 70 show wasn't on her radar
she cited the still recent conclusion to
the series as the reason behind The
Stance though she also stated that a
ways down the line she might be open to
a reboot it seems her instincts were
spoton for in 2023 Kunis and Ashton
Kutcher reprised their roles of Jackie
and Michael and returned to Point Place
Wisconsin for a brief cameo in the
sequel series that 90 show kunas felt
that it was important to support the
spin-off of the series that launched
their careers and Kutcher even told
Esquire that she was the force behind
their decision to appear in the show
Kunis was also outspoken about where her
character's life went telling Access
Hollywood that it felt out of place for
Jackie to end up with Kelso you know
what I called BS I was like my character
would be with Fez I think that I ended
up with wilmore's character